people are looking at the cost of energy
protein car loans mortgages there's no
question inflation is not going down
it's north of
32% the FED may have to increase rates
another 25 or 50 basis points as early
is January February it will be a very
hot political potato and it's going to
become an issue because it hits you
every day at the pump it hits you every
day at the grocery store and that is
what really hurts mandates Mr Wonderful
here and there's no debate about this
small businesses in America create over
60% of the jobs but times are tough is
there a solution yes the government
employee retention credit program go to
wonder trust.com today